I have the high ground welcome back
everybody I'm your host Ashcroft and
there has been so much Star Wars news
this week and so much yelling back and
forth online so we're gonna turn this
video into a bit of a Star Wars therapy
session I hope that's okay I'm joined by
fellow port nation member and host of
obsessed podcast and co-host a force on
a podcast writer comedian amazing person
Joseph scrimshaw thank you yeah did you
like that intro yeah I didn't say
amazing person when you're asking me how
I wanted to be described so the fact
that you just offered that that's very
rattling enough that's improv right
there a little later on the show I'm
gonna have an exclusive interview with
Mark Hamill his thoughts on alden
ehrenreich stepping into harrison ford's
rather large shoes as han solo
yeah just for you guys and at the end of
the show Joseph I'm going to ask you
what your most unpopular Star Wars
opinion is your hottest take so keep
that in mind back of the head for the
rest of the show but let's get to this
week's topic Game of Thrones creators
are developing a new Star Wars film
series there are more Star Wars films
coming Lucasfilm announced on Tuesday
that David Benioff and DB Weiss will
write and produce these undetermined
amount of movies the series will exist
separate from the main episodic
Skywalker saga and the recently
announced trilogy that Rian Johnson is
also working on there's so much Star
Wars coming no release dates have been
set they're probably really really far
off fans have very mixed reviews online
so this news came out two days ago have
you been able to process your thoughts
and feelings about this series we don't
know how many yeah keep wanting to say
trilogy because I feel like we're so
used to thinking in trilogy a lot of
people have said trilogy yes movies 87
it might be one and a half it might be
like now we're gonna stop this short
yeah who knows yeah so I like that it's
a little bit open-ended I I feel pretty
good about processing my Star Wars
feelings cuz I do it a lot I have so
many this is all we do ya learn to
process them quickly no I am I am
excited but I am excited with cabinets
like many people on the Internet I love
Game of Thrones but I agree with the
criticism that they haven't always
handled it
issues well on the show and I do wish
that Lucasfilm would announce some more
films that are being held by women or
people of color so I have those caveats
yes but I am excited to see what these
guys do with Star Wars right I mean I
think what it was announced I was of
course extremely excited I love Game of
Thrones I'm excited for these guys to
see what they could do but agreed like I
think the criticisms are totally valid I
also don't think that it has to be so
black and white like you don't have to
hate it or love it yeah you can
definitely love it and still be like
okay
yes but yeah yeah I think that's a good
emotional state always for Star Wars I'm
excited but I'm excited with with
concerns yes and again they are writing
and producing they're not necessarily
directing the movie so hopefully this is
the opportunity to bring in some
different voices yeah yeah exactly get
some different perspectives I think that
would be great
but in terms of like what they're gonna
do with it the idea of that their skill
sets are telling like big war stories
through the very personal that's really
interesting when you're dealing with
something that's called you know star
wars star wars wars of the stars yeah
I'm I saw a lot of people had already
edited lightsabers into some of the
sword fight sort of happened in Game of
Thrones
and you're watching that and you're just
like you're watching the Brienne and
Arya kind of going head to head
yeah I'm flipping around their swords at
stuff and I'm like yes we could get the
best lightsaber battle we've ever seen
whatever movie yeah maybe one they're
doing is just one long lightsaber battle
just two and a half hours but I think it
raises a lot of questions in that they
are very good most would say I think at
adapting material that already exists do
you think that they will do that do you
want to see that or do you want to see
them do something that doesn't exist
like maybe something in the EU or yeah I
think that they're gonna play around in
the Old Republic time frame that's been
that's your natural barfy I know I'll uh
I think that that is a genius idea by
the way I love like the Knights of the
Old Republic era I absolutely think they
should do that it's just whenever
anything is announced the entire
Internet is like right so they over
oh my god I understand I don't think
Ryan Johnson's doing anything with
Knights the Old Republic or the Old
Republic Knights the Old Republic is the
game and that would be a correct
adaptation and I think that's the
interesting thing because I ger when he
was announcing that said that they were
interested in a specific time frame
right that's the most obvious time frame
where it's an easy sell where you just
go to the world especially you know
people have been Star Wars fans for a
long time it's like would you like to
see a hundreds Jedi and hundreds of Seth
fight and like people like yeah and
these are the perfect people to do that
it's the most obvious thing for them to
do outside of the skywalker trilogy so i
think that's why the whole internet is
immediately like older public and then
you are immediately i think this is the
time i think the big question is are
they gonna adapt stuff from the
narrative that's been established in the
videogames in the books are they just
gonna be like it's Jenna it's if it's
thousands of years ago they're fighting
I feel like they will I think it's gonna
be like a loose adaptation like I don't
think they're gonna verbatim trying to
take anything yeah I think they'll do an
exact videogame shot-for-shot yep like
shop your shot some points the movie
like freeze yeah yeah just a bunch of
lag it's processing now a lot of people
were also talking about because of Game
of Thrones and the nudity and the
violence and the sex and all of that
whether or not Star Wars will ever be
r-rated or if it should be r-rated what
are your thoughts I see no reason to
make an r-rated Star Wars stuff I agree
with you yeah because they've always
been able to handle adult content
without being graphic you know I treated
about this but like you look at
something like Revenge of the Sith where
you know Anakin goes to the dark side
and murders children chokes his wife
gets his limbs cut off by his best
friend then burns in a river of flames
like we can have dark stuff and it works
even in the force awakens reverie is
like this is a fun family film that we
all go to during the holiday time where
a son brutally murders his father he's
one of the most popular characters ever
then he falls into a shaft in the world
explodes into its side you know for
family and it's again same thing with
rogue one like I think it maybe is
harder for kids to wrap their head
around the fact that everyone in that
movie just dies at the end but that is
what happens yeah it starts as a special
thing I'm not a parent but I've talked
to parents a lot like up for a while
there was like pillows and he's like a
mass murderer and every time I ask a
parent like how do you feel about it
like just an opportunity to talk to my
kids so I feel like Star Wars exists in
this space where it is this myth it is
there's a parable where you can use it
as a way to deal with these darker
questions without getting super graphic
about it right because there's no I mean
aside from the scene in the Mos Eisley
cantina I don't think there's any blood
in Star Wars at all I think that's it
right yeah I think that's about it yeah
there's some blood on Zeb seska's face
wrote to when he dies in Empire Strikes
Back just a little bit just a little bit
that's all they have just a flick is oh
that's Oliver blood no and it's like we
I mean I have assumed he saw Star Wars
as a child and it wasn't like last year
you saw it for the first time but um I
like I watched it as a kid and I never
knew that there were these darker themes
into it until you get older and you
watch it back and you're like oh this is
intense yeah yeah and I was just like
space yeah and princess yeah and I just
don't think we need gore and certainly
not nudity I think we could even know if
you wanted to get more sexy with Star
Wars Star Wars has always had romance
but it's been very chaste but I think if
you wanted to some of the books there's
like sex but I still think you could
shoot it in a way that's like hey
they're having sex over there right not
in a like which really zoom in on these
Jedi hips I don't think that's necessary
no and in the last Jedi Maz Kanata
straight up is like I hooked up with the
Cobra or Justin Theroux yes exactly and
we don't need to see it please we don't
need to see it there's a brief pause
where Rian Johnson allows us to picture
it ourselves
just that beat afterwards happen and
rose like hmm let me imagine that
sometimes the unknown is even sexier
than anything we could have possibly
seen so we've kind of touched on what
you would want to see in these potential
films and by the way they never even
exclusively said like they're theatrical
I mean I assume they are and that's the
safest bet but it could be like they're
working on this streaming service what
if they just drop like a bunch of movies
on there well that would be amazed
if it was like oh and by the way they're
not even in the movie theater Star Wars
I don't I don't think that will ever
happen I feel like it's such a that's
such a money opportunity to put them in
theaters I think but I mean I do think
when whatever series they're working on
next will be a streaming service thing
that's such a good way to get everyone
into oh yeah yeah I mean and then they
know it's yeah I think in that same
meaning that they've got multiple
television shows and development for
that streaming service so it's coming in
for sure do you feel like with all of
these announcements we're probably gonna
get one by the time this video is online
we're gonna get another something do you
feel like there is Star Wars fit fatigue
too much Star Wars do you feel
oversaturated by it no not at all
because I think we are getting this
weird perception that there's way too
much Star Wars because we're getting
these announcements and I think we're
getting them at what I call icon which
is basically just Bob hikers talking to
investors I think we're strangely
getting these announcements
whenever Bob Iger wants to tell people
with money what they're making we're not
getting them when fans necessarily need
to hear them so it sounds like what two
more trilogies eight yeah but the
reality is han Solo is gonna come out
the rebels TV show is gonna be off the
air and then it's gonna be a year and a
half until episode 9 mm-hmm and I swear
when December comes and there's no new
Star Wars movie like there has been for
the last three years every is gonna be
like Star Wars that is sad to me like
there's gonna be nothing in December
there's no celebration this year yeah
exactly
yeah that's sad yeah so right now maybe
feels like oversaturation because we're
getting an announcement in news every
day but I think it's gonna that's really
true and I also think it's because
there's so much unknown like we have no
idea what's happening beyond Episode
nine as far as what the films are gonna
be we just know that they exist like you
know there's stuff coming yeah in the
pipeline but we don't know what it is so
I feel like it's also kind of hard to
wrap your head around it because you're
like I don't know what's coming at all
yeah yeah and you have no idea the
release dates if they'd be staggered
like it's gonna be a Rian Johnson movie
then yeah Dan and Dave yeah we have to
do little dances to try to figure what's
it gonna look like yeah is there
anything in the
don't date my dandy
DB Weiss double D's the double D's
that's not all right
that you would not want to see I don't
want grimdark Star Wars now I don't
think that the game of thrones does this
it certainly has the potential to do it
and it has potential when you get into
like it's Jedi and Sith and it's all the
real serious stuff and cool battles and
people in armor they would get like real
serious and suddenly we would have like
all brooding chiseled Jedi Knights doing
like Jedi CrossFit and everything's very
serious that's the only thing I don't
want I don't want to get into kinda like
the tone that some of the the DC films
have had it's in the right and Superman
I think it's important that Star Wars
always balances cool Darth Vader walk
down a hall in slot of rebels with a
little bit of sense of like fun and
whimsy right I feel like I'm kind of
craving like a very bright colorful Star
Wars film like because I feel like when
those Han Solo character posters came
out I was like these are so beautiful
and I feel like and it's not that I I
have any hate towards the Han Solo movie
I'm very excited for it but I just feel
like the tone from the posters to the
trailer is so different like the trailer
is very dark Star Wars like like we've
seen and I'm kind of craving something
right Thor Ragnarok II different yeah
and I kind of hope we get that at some
point yeah I would love that
and there's a part of me that feels like
maybe the actual finished solo film will
be a little bit brighter right because I
mean if you have a costume meeting like
what should Lando wear the yellowish
shirt that could ever yellow better at
some point it will pop on screen you
know he is hashtag fashion gold so I
know it's like scapes
I don't really cosplay but I think this
is a good time to start
yeah I might just go to Comic Con just
wear a cape and no other cosplay and
just say I'm from Star Wars
everyone everyone will be like yes
everyone I'll tell you a different
character let's move on to the interview
of the week every single episode I will
give you guys a Star Wars interview it
might be brand new or it might be
something from the depth of
et vaults but either way it'll be
something that you can only find here on
this show isn't that great so I talked
to mark hamill on Monday night that's
amazing pretty rad and I asked him how
he felt about the Han Solo movie
obviously he knows that character of Han
Solo pretty well and there's this 28
year old kid stepping into those shoes
pretty big shoes so I take a look the
Star Wars divisive Ness has switched
over this morning to the Han Solo movie
because the trailer came out this
morning yeah have you seen it there's
decisiveness can you believe it you know
this is the only franchise where you go
on Twitter and they say if such-and-such
happens I am so out yes so now they're
speculating about things they don't want
to see it surprises me but look you
can't please everybody you just have to
try and make the best story you can I
was sort of taken aback by it but who
knows not everybody likes broccoli some
people like carrots or Brussels sprouts
better so you know that's just the way
life is
would you have advice for this alden
ehrenreich who's stepping into these he
can't win well of course I mean anybody
plays a young anything like when they
did the young Indian or the prequel to
Butch Cassidy and the Sundance Kid and
Tom Berenger William Kent were great but
they said oh well he's not like Robert
Redford he's not like Paul Newman that's
already hard but the trailer looks
fantastic I don't know anybody's
complaining about trailer makes you want
to see the movie and I'm dying to see it
so it works so you're in my he's right
like all that Ehrenreich is kind of
damned if he does an imitation of
Harrison Ford and damned if he doesn't
yeah but either way he's under the
biggest microscope possible yeah just
like hey why don't you uh take all of
these decades of not Han Solo but
Harrison Ford like people are putting
are asking him to play Harrison for mmm
I just need him to be han Solo in a
young Han Solo yeah you know did you
were you Matt server celebration in
Europe by any chance I was not did you
see the footage where he's like on the
stage because he to me that and I've
said this in so many videos so I'm sorry
if I'm saying this again but he was so
charismatic
very
to me and there was a moment he's
talking about stepping on the Millennium
Falcon and he's like I was stepping on
the Falcon for the first time and I'm
like like I was really I'm really into
him yeah and I feel like he doesn't need
defending it's like I feel like the
movie needs more defending than he does
character I don't care if he sounds
exactly like Harrison Ford if he's got
charm if he's got charisma great I don't
know why I can't stop talking about hips
on this video but if you watch the Han
Solo a teaser trailer every like profile
shot
he's got Harrison Ford sort of like the
hips the posture you know like the
energy you're right there's there's the
shot where he's talking to Emilia
Clark's character Keira and when she's
like I know what you are or something
like that and he says what's that and I
had it kind of paused on my computer
while I was cutting piece and I looked
over and I was like Harrison nope that
solo yeah yeah the moment that really
really sold me so what what are your
overall thoughts on the movie and did
the trailer and things that we've seen
so far now that stuff's starting to roll
out do they make you more excited less
excited or just the same I'm really
excited for it because I feel like Star
Wars has always been about like the
force and the fate in the destiny and
then also you have sort of the Leia
rogue one world of the rebellion and
responsibility and duty and government
and then you've got the scoundrel the
lucky guy gambler the aliens you know in
the rough-and-tumble world and I feel
like that big part of Star Wars that we
haven't spent as much time with is being
lifted out and given its whole entire
movie and it just looks like fun it
looks like it is based on the you know
original ideas behind Star Wars which
are like those adventure serials Flash
Gordon it's like great I'm a dead
dive-bar now I'm gambling now I'm at a
fancy jazz bar now I'm you know stealing
from a train attacked by a space octopus
like and no shirt is yellow just all
these exciting thrilling things man I
really like I really want to land a
movie now even just seeing Donald Glover
as whether you're just like it is
because I when the movie was announced
and I think we've talked about this
before it's like I didn't want to see
the Kessel run I don't want to see the
life-debt thing I don't want to see the
losing the Falcon like it's all these
stories that I like to imagine in my
head but then you see the trailer and
you're like you know what there's so
many characters we haven't met there's
so many elements of the story that are a
mystery in a good way yeah
I'm really into the idea of it now yeah
yeah and just like how does the Falcon
get so dirty so fast is such a great
internet meme ended true
good question like honestly what it's
such a compelling mystery like and what
did they haul in that ship I hope it
happens in the movie to the point where
like Lando has to see the Falcon and is
like look I know he says that and Empire
as well as like some some version of
that but I just want the full emotional
reaction from Lando yeah like a big 360
walkthrough video yeah where do you just
like because what could it possibly have
what could have possibly happened yeah I
think they hold some more wrath tires in
there and they just rolled around yeah
they socks and taken yeah pizza boxes oh
my god these pizza boxes for sure that's
a bachelor you had an intergalactic
kegger yeah now Joseph yes I asked you
at the beginning of the show what your
most unpopular Star Wars opinion is
because I like to light up my own
comments section no it can it can be
something that's really really hot take
or it can be something that's just kind
of mild that most people just don't
agree with yeah well you look I have so
many I walking unpopular Star Wars
opinion because I enjoy I appreciate the
prequels but I'll pick one specific
moment from the prequels that I people
make fun of I understand why but I think
it's good I think it's works I think
when obi-wan Kenobi declares that he has
the high ground and that is tactical
advantage that Anakin should not try to
overcome it gets great why do you think
it's great because the story of that
fight is that obi-wan has to defeat
Anakin and he has to mess him up real
real bad and there also has to be a
narrative reason why obi-wan wins so we
need a tactical reason that obi-wan can
say to Anakin hey here's a pause in the
fight it's not just oh sorry I cut your
legs off it has to be a tactical reason
of like Anakin I have some sort of
tactical advantage and don't let your
hubris allow you to fall to my
confidence in wisdom because that's the
advantage that obi-wan has so while I
understand people like what anytime that
anybody is on like you then you pull up
like a little
stole and you stand on that and then you
can beat Darth Vader cuz you have the
high ground I understand the jokes but I
think from a storytelling point of view
that allows you to appreciate it
obi-wan is the smart one he is the calm
one he is the wise one yeah
in Anakin is full of his anger and his
fear and the doubt and you know I have a
beat to pause in the story that I think
that's really well explained I I don't
hate that moment at all I think the meme
is like hilarious whenever people just
insert it into conversation like I have
a grandad funny it makes me laugh yeah
prequel memes are the best but I never a
problem with that moment okay now yeah a
lot of people that makes no sense you
know I can pick a lot of other lines
from the same movie that I would rather
but you know okay well thank you so much
for coming in absolutely let everyone
know where they can find you because I
was on your podcast
that's right yeah and we talked about
porks and stuff yeah talk about ports
and good bad movies so I have a podcast
called obsessed that you can find on my
website at Joseph scrimshaw dot-com
people just talk about things they love
a lot - talked about all the good bad
movies that she like I've also got my
Star Wars podcast force center and you
can find out all my comedy albums all my
live shows that Joe subscription com
awesome well you guys let us know what
you think about these Game of Thrones
Star Wars movies I don't really know
what to call them at this point so I'm
just winging it you let us know in the
comments and you can always tweet us our
handles are gonna be right here for you
I do this every time it's like kind of a
bit now thank you guys so much for
watching I will see you next week